Hello freak bitches. So, okay. Gender, Jordan Peterson. Um,
so I'm completely absolutely with him. You know when it comes to that,
when it comes to policing of language and,
but he, as I said, he, I, I re I could be wrong about this,
but it sounded to me,
and I've listened to him on your show and I've listen to him elsewhere and a lot
of people have pointed him to me and vice versa cause they think we agree on
these things and we don't, which is that he thinks,
it seems to me that gender is biologically determined that there are two
genders, they're fixed in nature. And that's the end of that discussion.
If he's ever said that. I don't know. I really don't think he has. Yeah,
I really don't.
Well I think you said that when it comes to gender identity that he doesn't
believe that we need more pronouns. No, he thinks it's just wrong.
If you think you're a woman when you were born with a penis, it's just by,
it's just sort of absolutely wrong.
I think you'd have to find him saying that before you really glad to hear you
say that. Cause I wasn't sure where you stood on that. No, I mean fuck man,
that's a big deal. I think that's a big deal. It can get super weird when,
okay. How about Rachel Dolezal, she identifies as being black, right? Yeah,
she's a trans racial. How do you feel about that? I think she's correct.
Ah, not now. Hang on, let me, let me, uh,
let me tell you what correct means. They're not in a,
not in an absolute way, right? Not in a scientific objective way,
but it's just as true as anything else.
Meaning that because so race and the, here's where a, here's,
here comes Sam Harris now and I'm sure Jordan Peterson's in this boat too,
but I know Sam Harris's,
cause I just heard him talking about this with Charles Murray. Um,
he believes there's, there are races of people.
He thinks that race is a real thing. He's,
he's definitely subtle about it and nuanced. He says, you know,
it's the divisions between races and the lines are blurry and you know,
but he believes there's a biological basis to race. He's very clear about that.
And that is to me, absurd and completely unscientific.
And it's easily disprovable by according to his own standards and by scientific
standards. But then you see a black guy from Kenya, you see a white,
a Chinese guy from China. [inaudible] what's the difference? No difference.
Well, here's, here's the answer you tell me. Right? Which is that.
So historically,
the differences between them have changed that we, people,
human beings have said different things have created different categories and
fill those categories with different characteristics over the centuries.
Those have changed constantly, right? And my first time I was on here,
we had a long discussion about what's in my book,
the Renegade history on immigrants and the Irish and the Italians and the Jews.
When they got here to the United States here and in Europe,
they were largely considered to be Negroes, right? Right.
And now there is white. Does anybody, right? So what are they? Um,
at that time in the early 20th century, it was not like,
when I say common belief, I mean it was taught in schools.
The following taught at Harvard,
the following that Europeans were made up of three distinct races.
There were the Nordics and Northern Europe, the Alpines in central Europe,
and the Mediterraneans in the S in Southern Europe.
And they were very different biologically.
The Nordics were rational, intelligent,
disciplined. They were the ones who made civilization.
They should run the country. The Alpines were okay.
They could be decent farmers, but they're never going to do algebra.
And they certainly can't run a government.
The Mediterraneans were basically either like Negroes are really close and
therefore should be slaves or just peasants. That's my people. Yeah, no, yeah.
You're talking about a long time ago. No,
we're talking about a hundred years ago, which historically, long time ago,
you're holding your breath. But you know, you love ancient history. I mean,
if you look at the whole sweep of human history, that's five minutes ago, right?
It is. But it's still a long time in terms of how we address it today.
But if we address it today, if you're looking at it,
someone from China or you're looking at a dark black man from Kenya, yeah,
there's something different about them. Do you think it's just melanin? Sure,
of course. There's something different about them right now.
Many different things. Where do you draw the line about around races though?
Right? So look at, take all the people in Kenya. Okay. Um,
which ones are Kenyans and which ones are they all Kenyans and what makes them
Kenyan or are they all Africans? Well, you know, you can do, they all black,
right? So those are all passed on someone and find out where their,
their origins are. You can find out how much Irish you have in you,
how much South African you can meet. You can do all that.
You can go all the way back to, you know, your family lineage through jeans.
I get that total. If you want to go all the way back, we're all African. Sure.
Well there you go. That's another way to disprove this whole thing. Right,
right. But it's disproving it because I mean these proving it. Sorry,
that's a bad word to use. Here it is calling it out as a fiction,
as a social construct,
which is that these lines have been drawn all the time in all kinds of different
ways over the centuries by human beings who just look at all the people in the
world. They line up the 7 billion people right in their mind,
and they draw lines and say, Oh, these people over here and this side,
those are the Negroes. And over here, these are the Mongoloid.
And over here these are the Asiatics. And over here these are the Nordics.
And over here are the Ariens and the Jews and dah, dah, dah.
And those change all the time. But these are just categories we invent, right?
So who's black? Jimi Hendrix? Black. Well,
Jimmy Hendricks has a mixed background, right? I mean, wasn't his mother white?
What's his race? What's his race? Is he black or white? It's a good question.
There you go. Got it. A lot in them, but so,
but there's a big difference between someone like Jimmy Hendrix and someone that
like very, very dark. Okay.
Comes from a specific part of the world where everyone around them is very,
very dark. Let's do that.
Very obvious and repeatable characteristics that Congo,
these knives come from the Congo. Okay. The people there,
they're Pygmies actually it's an even more specific group.
We can just even do West Africans. Okay. Where a slaves,
where the West of where the Western slaves, American slaves come from. Um,
and just across the continent, not even that far away. You know,
there's Somalia, you know what Somalians look like, right? Yeah.
And Ethiopians, right.
You think about them and how they look and think about how, you know, uh, West,
uh, West Africans look, are they the same race? Well, very,
very physical characteristics. Very dark. Somali.
Somalis looked different than everybody clearly. Right. You know,
as Somali immediately, right? Same continent, same pigmentation basically.
Very thin. Yeah. Their facial structure, very different. Uh,
why are they black? Why are they the same race?
Is the question that the same race or, I mean what I'm saying about Somalians,
like would you,
would you consider Somalians the same as like Ethiopians or as the same as
Egyptian? My thing is also Africa.
My thing is let's get rid of these categories.
These are all silly made up categories. There's no reason to.
They're all arbitrary. Okay.
The lines have been drawn between groups of people arbitrarily over the
centuries. Well, what did you see?
You're arguing against something that Sam Harris said.
So what did Sam Harris say specifically Tim? Him. It's a lot of people.
So you don't agree that there is any race at all?
I'm just saying it's a fiction. It's made time, right? It's just, it's like,
is it a fiction?
How is it a way we're trying to define the variations between human groups
because there are variations. Oh, that's definitely what it's been about.
That's definitely been the motivation. Right?
And think about what the consequences have been. Okay. But it's never been good.
Just because there's consequences for variations or recognizing variations
doesn't mean you should stop recognizing actual variations, but then you make,
but they always make claims right after that. Like what? Sam Harris a straw man,
isn't it? I mean,
you don't have to make a claim that Chinese people are different because they
look different. No. But then it's just, well,
this is what a Chinese person generally they have these very stringent
characteristics. They don't have blonde hair,
they don't have blue eyes and not tall and skinny.
They look like Chinese future. But then again, Chinese people all look the same.
I mean, there's [inaudible] to say that, right? But again,
there's clear characteristics.
A difference between a Chinese person and a black person is very clear. Uh,
not really well and not always Kenyans who lives in Kenya who is born and raised
multiple generations deep. And their parents are Kenyan,
their grandparents are Kenyan.
There's a very big difference between them and someone who lives in Shanghai.
Yeah. But who was born in Shanghai? Their parents are born in Shanghai.
They go all the way back. You know, many,
many generations of being pure Chinese. Right.
But there are infinite variations even among the people who have lived only in
Shanghai. But what do you want to call the variations? Nothing but, but,
but you're talking about something that's clearly identifiable or you just
[inaudible]. I would say that there's, of course,
there are genes that run in families. And I completely agree that, you know,
genes determine in large part how we look fine.
So you can certainly say this person is likely because of their genes connected
to that person, last generation to that generation to this, you know,
and his family lineage. Sure. Well what does that give you? I dunno. Nothing.
I mean it's the thing is that people have taken that and they've said,
Oh well these particular characteristics are human beings.
We're talking about complexity and human beings at the beginning of this, right.
People are infinitely complex. Right. Okay.
So the thing is what people have done historically is they've just picked
certain characteristics among people and said, ah,
that is what determines your race is the issue.
The word race is maybe the issue.
Like there are obvious physical characteristics.
The difference between like a someone who is a Mongol versus someone who a is a
Brazilian versus someone who is,
there's some pretty obvious physical characteristics for geographic areas.
Which would you agree like or common physical characteristics for some
geographic areas? Sure.
You could say on average people in China are shorter than people in Polynesia.
Here's the place where you could do it. Canada, like try to find a Canadian,
like you don't know what a Canadian looks like. They could be English,
they could be American,
they could use trying to entertain your strongest argument. Okay, so like China,
right. You could certainly say that people in China are on average, on average,
shorter than people in Polynesia. Right? Well, they look different. Yeah,
but that's one way in which they look different. A facial,
you're talking about physiognomy facial features, bone structure.
Polynesians find to be like really stout people. Suppose you could say,
you know the,
the width of their eyes is narrower or whatever on average and whatever. Sure.
Okay. Okay, so what, that's it. I mean what did we, okay, so they,
they are likely to be in lineage from that part of the world.
Fine. That's cool. I've got no problem with that.
But what else do you want to say? The thing is, Joe, no one stops there.
They always go on to that.
They always go on from there and they start to make all these other claims. Oh,
well that race is really good at math. Their IQ is higher.
This is what actually Sam Harrison, Charles Murray were just saying.
They can do the, they can do the, um,
they can do the coding for Google better than, than other people can, whatever.
Right. They are more, they are more scrupulous. They smoke cigarettes more,
whatever it is, you know,
they used to be accused of being a more easily addicted to opium, you name it.
Right. Things change. But that's the problem is that once you start there,
people have those differences for other reasons,
almost always,
which are nefarious and injurious and have done terrible things to people.
Your problem is recognizing those characteristics and those differences and
calling it a race and then attaching all sorts of other claims to this category.
Precisely. Okay. Yeah, that's exactly what Sam and Charles Murray,
this is Charles Murray's thing, although it's actually,
it's only a small part of his work and he gets accused of it being central and
it's not, but anyway, he does still nonetheless believe this.
And so does Sam Harris.
And so do other people that there are differences in IQ among races.
Okay. Now on the surface level, they are completely correct.
There's no question meaning that IQ scores among people that we identify as
African American have been lower than among the people we define as white
American. Totally true, totally true.
And they are right that that is suppressed,
that we are not allowed to even talk about that data, which is there and it's,
I have no problem with that. I'm sure that's true. Here's the thing though.
How do we define African American and how do we define white first?
That's the first problem. Those, as you know,
definitions have changed over time.
So Jews used to be in the African American group and Italians used to be in the
African American group. No, no, never. Never called African Americans.
They were, they were called Negroes. Well, yes, they were.
Jews were called Negroes. A book written Xin.
My book Renegade history in ninth in 1911 there was a book written by a scholar
and this was one of many, the title of which his name was Arthur Abernethy,
the title of which was the Jew is a Negro. That's the title of it.
This was common. This is what people is what year this is.
This is all through the late 19th and early 20th centuries from about the 1880s
when the Jews started coming over in big numbers from the 1880s into the 1940s
this was, I'm not,
I'm saying this is what was taught in college classrooms that Jews were of a
different race and there was some difference of opinion about whether they were
black or whether they were just some other kind of inferior race,
but they certainly weren't white. That was,
that was widely agreed upon until world war II basically. All right,
so how do we define African-American? Is Jimmy Hendricks African-American?
Does he keep talking? There's a big difference,
isn't there in the term African American versus Negro, right.
Because like it's the same thing.
It's just a different name for the same category. Yeah. But it's from Africa.
They knew that these Jews weren't from Africa. So the,
so the one drop is a continent. I dunno. They believe that they,
they believe that the genes and they're right about this, right.
The jeans [inaudible] yeah. So that's, you know,
and they're bright but so do all of our genes. Right, right. Um,
so that was part of their claim and that they were from, you know,
part of Europe that was a bit closer to African.
This is what they said about Italians in particular, Sicilians, right.
They were like, all right, look where it is. That's why these people, you know,
are fucking all the time and having babies and crew and are lazy and can't work
and fight and bars and get drunk and, right. Right. So,
so how do we define these terms? What does white mean? That's totally changed,
but how much of it is right? The real guys, just how much of it is cultural?
So there's that hold on and then, and then IQ. Well,
um, I think it does measure something. I think that's real. I do, I really do.
I think there is something called, this is a G factor, which it, it, it,
it tests, it measures G factors. This thing that was invented, this concept.
It's a category but it's a real category in the world we operate in,
which is your ability to do rational thinking,
reasoning like math,
like writing scholarly essays. You know,
I'm sure my G factor is higher sort of than other people's,
although I'm terrible at math.
So that's yet another problematic wrinkle for these people. Um, but yeah,
I, I believe that IQ measures that stuff, that kind of thing.
But is that what intelligence is and only is
clearly, no, no, no. There's a lot of variables that IQ does. Cute test tests,
right? The tests, all kinds of intelligence. They test emotional intelligence.
Do they test the intelligence of Jimmy Hendricks?
Do you think he was great at calculus? I don't know. I started out it,
was he smart? Was he intelligent? Clearly in different ways.
Clever with a guitar, that's for sure. So then how do you define intelligence?
Fellow creativity is unquestionably some sort of measurement or expression of
intelligence. We separate that off though. And we always have as a society,
we shouldn't. That's why you don't do well unless you're really, really,
really good. If you're just creative.
And the way we define that and not intelligent in the way IQ tests to find it,
there's a, so it's all problematic. Um,
and just all it does is ask question. It just keeps raising new questions.
It never has answers. And so that the attempt to,
there's this thing that goes on where like certain people just need to keep
finding racial differences that are innate, biological,
fixed that can't be changed. And it's like, first of all,
you've never done this because it's so fluid and you're always,
you never really answering it. And then what if you did finally prove it?
What are we going to do with that information? You know,
we just recognize that there are variables.
Like when you're talking about Polynesian people,
are we talking about people from Tonga, very stout, strong people,
Samoans tend to be very stout, strong people.
I mean that's a characteristic actually a positive characteristic that's
attributed to people from that area. Do you ignore that? Like,
how do you address that? Of course not.
I would say that people from Polynesia are more likely,
men from Polynesia are more likely to be offensive lineman in the NFL.
So your issue is calling it a ratio itself. Yeah.
And then attributing other things to it.
All I'm saying is guys from there tend to be bigger. Yeah. Hell yeah.
No doubt about it. But so what? That's the end of it.
Is there a part of the world where people are generally thought to be dumb?
Yeah. Africa, the country that the, sorry,
the the continent we've been talking about, that's,
that's the history of this country. This is the history of Europe.
That's the history of the modern world is the belief that people from Africa are
dumber than whites. Well,
isn't the problem that Africa is also where the pyramids were created?
That's what justified. That's what justified slavery.
That's what justified colonialism.
That's what justifies has justified all sorts of things. Right.
So that's the problem here is that these,
these attempts to define people by race and by the way, by gender,
have done nothing but terrible things.
Nothing but terrible things and you can't do it anyway.
It's scientific bullshit. It's total superstition. It's utterly arbitrary.
The lines are always being redrawn by the people who do this stuff.
So why are you still doing it guys?
Like it's where do you draw the goddamn line?
All the people in Africa are black. Really?
Egyptians are the same race as people from the Congo as the people from South
Africa, as the people from Somalia. I mean,
how are they the same race because it's pigment skin pigment.
Is that the only determination? Well,
it's a fascinating thing when you call people African Americans or call them
Italian-Americans because Italy isn't actually a country.
Whereas Africa is a continent. Fantastic point.
It's weird to call people [inaudible] who's an Italian, right?
Because guess what? Italy didn't even exist until the 19th century.
I mean it was just a bunch of city States until then,
and there was no such thing as an Italian.
People who lived there didn't call themselves a team. It wasn't a concept.
It wasn't a name of nothing.
And then they made it into this nation state that they called Italy.
And now ever since. Ever since then, every sorry,
but every dipshit Italian American is like really proud that I'm Italian. Well,
that dude that has no meaning really in the deepest history at a some weight
meaning sure. But they talk about it as if it's like rooted in nature.
Like it's biological. They love being a part of that stupid team. Soprano.
They lose Sopranos. It's tribalism. It's tribal as it is tribal,
and it's stupid. And if it were just stupid, I wouldn't care. It's that. It has,
as I said, it just leads to bad stuff.
[inaudible].